attitude contraste et au procès vilma
l'avocat général avait réclamé une peine
de 10 ans minimum contre jean-marie
villemin jugé pour le meurtre de bernard
laroche la défense souhaite
l'acquittement dominique verdeilhan
hervé poggio
la dernière touche avant la plaidoirie
d'un dossier que m chastan suit depuis
plus de huit ans jean marie villemin a
fait ce matin une confidence à son
conseil l'avocat général a fait mal à
jean marie villemin quand il a envisagé
sa dangerosité le réquisitoire a
scandalisé la défense comme la
scandalisé en 85 la rumeur qui a
transformé christine villemin en
criminel l'honneur d'une mère qu'on
jette aux chiens dénonce l'avocate
pensez vous que la justice puisse se
tromper deux fois interroge m chastan
autrement dit la première piste celle de
bernard laroche était la bonne pour
mettre robinet le corbeau est sûrement
venu à la barre et il cite nommément
frères et belles soeurs de l'accusé en
bloc la défense interroge la cour
d'assises comment devant ce
dysfonctionnement médiatico-judiciaire
jean marie villemin pouvait-il résister
m robinet invite les deux jurés à se
poser demain durant leur délibéré une
autre question qu'auriez vous fait à sa
place